gone to order the vote came just hours
before the Security Council
authorization allowing aid to be
delivered across the borders into Syria
was due to expire Russia had taken
things to the brink and in the end it
got its way this vote means the number
of crossing points will now be reduced
from 4 to 2 angering the US and the UK
who had no choice but to abstain they
could have used their veto but that
would have stopped all cross-border aid
deliveries this day is potentially one
of the saddest because it is the first
time that a Security Council member has
chosen to play politics with
humanitarian assistance and not only
play politics with the UN and
humanitarian assistance but in doing
that Russia is playing dice with the
lives of the Syrian people in the
Northeast negotiations have been
underway for weeks and right up until
the vote US ambassador Kelly Kraft took
personal charge of her country's efforts
meeting with every other member of the
council in an effort to persuade them it
is the Russian Federation that vetoed a
compromised proposal on December 20th
and has sensed worked tirelessly to
divide the council the only reasonable
conclusion to draw from these actions is
that the Russians actively triumphantly
support the Assad regime's to starve its
opposition it's estimated that one of
the two border crossings now no longer
authorized to operate ally Arabiya in
Iraq was responsible for bringing in aid
for up to 1.3 million people some of
them will still get aid through other
routes
according to humanitarian organizations
though others will not James BAE's al
Jazeera at the United Nations